epictetus was born a slave and
throughout the journey from a slave to a
philosopher he confronted all the
nuances that the spectrum of his journey
entailed that is perhaps the reason his
philosophy is so powerful his
experiences allowed him to leave his
philosophy and use it as a means for
survival and prosperity he was a firm
believer of the fact that an individual
can only be free if he frees himself
from his limiting beliefs and also his
addiction to the opinions of others he
was one of the first to see that there
is a way for one to be in control
insofar as one can control only the
things that are within his control
opinions perceptions views beliefs
stories are all manifestations of how
our mind adapts to the stimuli of the
environment sometimes they're true and
sometimes they're untrue one can't
control the extent to which truth is
being spoken by others but one can
certainly control the extent to which he
speaks the truth and how one reacts and
perceives the truth or untruth spoken by
others